a Shepard Smith is sometimes the lone
single I guess I would call him voice of
reason on Fox News and it must be pretty
tough for him right being the only one
there who ever is even remotely
connected to the real world in any case
Fox News has been at the forefront along
with other right-wing media outlets
pushing this bogus Hillary Clinton
uranium one conspiracy theory and every
once in a while like on live calls or
during a YouTube livestream
someone will ask me David why aren't you
covering the blockbuster Hillary Clinton
uranium one story and I'm not covering
it because it's a bogus debunked
conspiracy theory widely debunked and
there are endless important issues and
breaking news to discuss every single
day however I do want to talk about it
today because something very interesting
happened on Fox News Shepard Smith took
six minutes and destroyed the Hillary
Clinton uranium one conspiracy theory
which is particularly interesting
because Fox News has been one of the
primary purveyors of that conspiracy
theory and the reason it came up on Fox
News is because yesterday Jeff Sessions
Trump's attorney general again testified
and he was questioned by Democrats
mostly about possible and at this point
pretty clear lies and misstatements and
and deception around contacts between
the Trump campaign and Russia however
there were some Republicans who
questioned Jeff Sessions yesterday who
had no interest whatsoever and asking
him about the pressing matters which is
have you perjured yourself and how many
times have you lied under oath
they wanted to talk about other stuff
including but not limited to the Hillary
Clinton uranium one conspiracy theory so
that caused Shepard Smith to decide to
debunk the entire thing he seems to have
had enough he said so on Fox News here's
a little bit of Shepard Smith at least
trying to set the record straight to
what is probably not a particularly
receptive audience to be to being talked
out of a Hillary Clinton conspiracy
theory here's Shep now here's the
accusation nine people involved in the
deal made donations to the Clinton
Foundation totaling more than 140
million dollars
in exchange Secretary of State Clinton
approved the sale to the Russians a quid
pro quo the accusation first made by
Peter Schweitzer the senior editor at
large of the website Breitbart in his
2015 book Clinton cash the next year
candidate Donald Trump cited the
accusation as an example of Clinton
corruption Hillary Clinton State
Department approved the transfer of 20%
of America's uranium holdings to Russia
while nine investors in the deal
funneled 145 million dollars to the
Clinton Foundation that statement is
inaccurate in a number of ways first the
Clinton State Department had no power to
veto or approve that transaction it
could do neither so Shep went on like
this for a full six minutes picking
apart every aspect of this conspiracy
theory I won't play the full six minutes
for you you can probably find it online
if you want you can definitely find it
online if you want but if you already
understand that this is a debunked
conspiracy theory you probably have no
need for the full six minutes eventually
Shep Smith got to his conclusion with
this thing even so the accusation is
predicated on the charge that Secretary
Clinton approved the sale she did not a
committee of nine evaluated the sale the
president approved the sale the Nuclear
Regulatory Commission and others had to
offer permits and none of the uranium
was exported for use by the US to Russia
that is uranium one this was actually a
really really good explanation a
debunking of the entire story not where
we would normally expect to see such a
detailed debunking of a right-wing
conspiracy theory and as I was watching
this I was just imagining the core fox
news audience totally confused wondering
what on earth is happening on Fox News
and there's this really funny and also
kind of disturbing funny maybe it's not
the right word thing that happens when
but you see Shep Smith just talking
sense on fox news
there are many homophobic right-wingers
who understand
you can't just go around calling people
[ __ ] these days that generally speaking
sexual orientation even if you think
it's wrong to be gay lesbian whatever
that you don't want to just publicly
slam people for it with homophobic terms
because it's in most of the country now
not widely accepted but you go and look
at online forums where they are
discussing this clip or other stories
where Shep Smith has sort of departed
from the right wing talking points all
you see are comments like this guy's a
[ __ ] Shep is gay he can't be trusted what
do you expect from the gay guy on fox
news and you and I realized that being
gay has no bearing whatsoever on whether
you can accurately report on a
hypothetical uranium sale but these
right-wingers see something they don't
like on fox news and they revert
immediately to just homophobic slurs
it's like they can't control each other
if only sober factual explanations
actually changed Trumpets minds but the
Fox fans are furious with Shepard Smith
I was looking at some tweets earlier
today and people are just losing their
minds over this guy you need to get that
hack Shepard Smith out of Fox he just
made excuses for crooked Hillary and is
clearly a double agent hey Shep Hillary
took the hundred and forty five million
regardless of when it was sent
pay-for-play
you goof another tweet slamming Shepard
Smith I normally don't tune into chefs
hour on Fox can't stand his bias but
today while surfing channels he caught
my interest in three minutes he argued
Hillary's defense how she had nothing to
do with uranium one and how Trump had
lied about it he has to go turning on
Shep very quickly and what's really
funny is if you're watching TV with us
right now I have on screen a still shot
from the Sean Hannity program on the one
hand you've got Shep Smith completely
debunking uranium one and then on the
Sean Hannity program you have something
like look like it like out of the
Beautiful Mind the story the film with
Russell Crowe it's this crazy flowchart
of caen
Spira see that was taking place on the
exact same channel where Shepard Smith
completely debunked the story and then
on Laura Ingraham Fox News's newest host
she was all over the Hillary uranium one
thing how stupid does it make the
network look when in the afternoon Shep
Smith completely and totally debunked
the conspiracy theory and then Sean
Hannity and Laura Ingraham just go back
to talking about the conspiracy theory
like the debunking never happened and
the truth is that for the trumpets and
for the Fox and users who didn't see
Shep Smith's debunking it's like it
didn't happen and my only question is
how does Shep Smith get away with this
and I had a few thoughts about it one
possibility may be Shep Smith's contract
protects him and he can say whatever he
wants and he can't be fired I don't know
I don't know what his contract looks
like another option is that Fox News has
sort of calculated they say listen way
more people watch the evening stuff than
Fox News during the day so let's let
Shep say whatever the hell he wants
and then few people will see that
everybody will see the Hannity stuff in
the Ingraham stuff and then we can claim
that our network is a an incubator of a
variety of opinions because we're
allowing Shep Smith to do this stuff I
don't know the answer okay I don't know
why it is that Shep Smith is allowed to
do this stuff year after year maybe it's
because he doesn't do that much of it
it's like every six months we talk about
him it's unclear but a very good job
done by Shep here debunking this
conspiracy theory send me your thoughts
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman we'll be back
after this